my answer to everybody is the ability to  use LinkedIn both as a marketing channel  like a Facebook or a Google and as a  marketing channel for a personal brand  an individual to speak on subject matter  is the big opportunity for most people  on this call they just have to speak  about things they actually believe in  and want to talk about but they have to  make it as if they are on CNBC and are  an anchor or they write for the New York  Times or the Wall Street Journal not as  an executive there's not a soul on Earth  that wants to hear your press release  that your people wrote for you as a  LinkedIn post on the flip side if you  may pretend that you just retired and  you got a full-time job at CNBC or the  Wall Street Journal and you wrote about  macro issues that touch on your business  you can find yourself in very fruitful  grounds for business development